lionel groulx c'est le nom d'une station
de métro connu et fréquenté mais il
s'agit d'abord et avant tout d'une
figure majeure du nationalisme
canadien-français les chauriennes
toujours pensé prêtre catholique
professeur historien et écrivain
lionel groulx a aussi ses parts d'ombré
certains historiens la ceci à
l'antisémitisme
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la première fois que l'on
cherche à renommer la station
lionel-groulx cette fois l'instigateur
n'évoque pas le passé trouble du
chanoine mais celui brillant d'un
musicien montréalais au score pie xii
[Musique]
natif de montréal ce géant du jazz a
connu un grand succès aux états unis et
ailleurs dans le monde
aboya québec on a des légendes noires et
les peuples des couleurs qu'ils ont fait
beaucoup d addition à notre société
déjà la pétition compte près de 20 mille
signatures c'est quelque chose de
positif a dit qu' il y à l'aide des
changements qui venait année société
tellement ouvert mais l'idée de
déboulonner lionel groulx ne fait pas
l'unanimité en réponse à la pétition
vincent filteau on a lancé une deuxième
je demande simplement qu'on sacrifie pas
la mémoire de lionel groulx pour un orri
celle d'oscar peterson
selon lui la contribution et la mémoire
de l'homme d'église ne mérite pas de
disparaître j'ai eu un peu de difficulté
avec une conception militante de
l'histoire où on essaye seulement faire
tomber les coûts par un débat qui
s'inscrit bien dans l'air du temps
les statuts s'érige ce déboulonne la
mémoire elle aussi est appelé à changer
il faut créer les conditions de ce dépôt
quelles sont les valeurs qu'on veut
honorer dans l'espace public
et ça c'est une discussion qui est
démocratique c'est une discussion qui
est politique qui doit prendre place les
pétitions qui circulent en trouver et
court jusqu'au bureau de la mairesse
elle explique que les noms donnés aux
stations de métro deviennent au fil du
temps des repères géographiques pour le
service de transport et pour ses
utilisateurs
valérie plantes reconnaît cependant
qu'il est sain de remettre en question
les décisions du passé ici qui me
permettrait au canada montréal